Okay.
And there were probably
people thinking about it too.
Okay.
And I am not complaining about it because
I just want to be
so the same.
I don't understand that
and though I'm not the doctors
I think
we just don't understand
what the brain is.
But
you woke up
all night
Saturday, right?
I'll send you an article that I sent to my mom.
It's very insightful on...
I am talking.
I don't want to say...
Well, you're asking what's going on.
I don't understand.
The article
is writing
the premium.
I want you to read it unless you read it
and there's no point in having this conversation
because you're alluding
to something that I've been thinking about
every single day that I've talked about
hundreds of times, hundreds of thousands of times.
Like the question that you're asking
is something that I've been trying to ask
and answer for myself so many more times
than you have just now
and so that's why I want you to read it
because you're...
it's like...
I mean, you know...
otherwise there's no point in talking about it at all
and I'm just going to end the conversation here right now.
But you think...
Can you summarize that article?
No, not really.
It's a very short article.
Please.
It's all in your work.
Huh?
We don't know what's going on.
We don't know what happens with the brain.
Not even the doctors know.
Treatment is completely ineffective
and euthanasia should be possible for people like me.
Even doctors...
Even some doctors support it.
So...
Basically...
The conclusion of this article is that
you are...
Terminal is...
And that's why they...
It's not a...
There's no conclusions in this article.
It's not such a decisive article.
That's why I want you to read it
because it's nuanced.
You told me to summarize it the way...
Yeah, I am not speaking it.
You don't know that.
Well then why are you like,
"Oh, the conclusion of the article is..."
When there's obviously no conclusion.
But you wouldn't know that
because you haven't read it.
I have...
Or you refuse to read it.
I refuse to read it.